pleased to have right here on my set the
president of the Houston Texans Jamey
Rootes hey rich good to be with you man
to see you I've been to the same room
with you for the last decade we've just
never run into each other marker that
amazing I know such a small family data
is without be sure to say hi next time
what you please certainly I've been an
honor owners meeting in a while you just
came back from the one in New York
correct yeah that was yesterday the
commissioner said that the personal
conduct policy was discussed for five
hours can you let us in him a little bit
what it was really the thought it was
really the focus I mean there was a lot
of good progress great discussion some
education that was part of that he's
very complicated issue it's not a for
not a football issue or sports issue
it's a societal issue and we're
wrestling with it we made good progress
yesterday and will continue to push
forward until we we gets up and get
something to push the issue is what to
do with somebody when they're pop for
something and and and when they can
actually return to the field and you
can't just throw somebody on a list for
with without good cause sure and you
also can't just have them sit on your
team if they're in the court of public
opinion already being viewed as guilty
it just seems to be something that that
that no sport can get their handle on
how how are you guys dealing with that
well there there have been complicated
issues forever right and so what you do
is you get a group of people together
smart people great advisors that the
league has engaged and you you discuss
the issues and you you go back and forth
get lots of opinions and you you come up
with a good solution you know right
Roger made a comment that you're not
gonna let perfect get you know get in
the way of better you know a progress
we're going to move forward on this
thing but you know you you just yet you
just have to make progress that's where
we are well what about taking care of
your own house cuz we sort of from my
position talking about this islet nobody
tunes in his sports show is wanting it
to sound like the nightly news right so
I'm sometimes just sort of lost it on
the air a little bit couple weeks ago
just saying well
way to fix this problem is not to have
anybody get into the problem in the
first place yeah so what about taking
care of your own house share your own
53-man with your own practice squad what
are the Texans doing on this front to
make sure on the preventive aspect is
taken care of well you have lots of
people who are cycling through your
organization you know and as we
mentioned earlier this is a societal
issue right so you do the best job that
you can on the front end to evaluate the
character of the men that'll be part of
your football program and the people
that will be a part of your
administrative staff when we first
started the Texans remember our first
ever meeting Bob only spent about a
minute or a minute and a half he said
it's really easy around here you know
I'll never do anything to embarrass you
and I expect that none of you will ever
do anything to embarrass me and that's
the type of mentality that we've
operated with we're not always perfect
but you've got to do your best and then
when you have issues or instances learn
from that and get better this is a get
better league and we're going to get
better from this situation I tell you we
look back on this I think this is going
to be a critical turning point where the
National Football League led society by
addressing an issue that nobody's been
you know up for taking on in the past
right and but you know there are some
people in society saying if that the
leadership before was not up to snuff
and now it's just a back filling
situation to try and get to that point
how do you respond to folks were
criticizing the NFL still even after the
steps that have been taken I don't I
don't respond you respond with your
actions you know me words are easy right
and so yesterday was another good step
in the process for the National Football
League the discussion the dialogue will
continue I know Roger and his team in
New York are working on this constantly
until we get a program that we can roll
out that will make a difference but
beyond the punishment and that piece of
it I mean you've got the education that
needs to go on there's the counseling
that needs to be part of this all of
these are very important components of
what is a comprehensive program where we
will be better for having had this
experience and I think will serve as an
example for the balance of sports and
for the balance of society in a couple
of minutes I have with your lesser three
to talk about get better leading yeah
you guys have gotten better very fast
what where do you place the texans in
your mind five games into the season
getting set for a big game tonight well
there's a lot of transition this
offseason you know when you good and bad
you have a season like we did you have
the number one selection we have a new
coaching staff led by Bill O'Brien it's
brought in you know it is great guy he's
tough he's disciplined our teams were
all prepared we're Team first he talks
about this being a get better league and
you know the only place that when comes
before work is in the dictionary so
we're getting better like that yeah
jinsong book that is it has a little bit
about this okay but we're getting better
and tonight is an opportunity for us to
you know take on our rival you know with
the AFC south on the line at least the
lead at this point in time we're just
going to try to get better each time
that we go out and hopefully we aren't
an opportunity to be in the playoffs
maybe we win our division and then we'll
go from there it's incredible how have
you I don't remember the last time
somebody signed a huge contract and
within days actually started paying
dividends it's JJ Watt is essentially a
dream come true in so many ways not only
with his an own self but for the
franchise I've just in the last minute I
give you the floor yeah on JJ Watt well
JJ watt's an incredible talent right you
see that every Sunday JJ Watt works as
hard as anybody in any locker room after
he signed his contract the next day at
three or four in the morning he's
working out right you know to
demonstrate that I'm committed to
showing that I'm worth this but what he
does in the community is absolutely
amazing and that has not tailed off at
all has he seen success in fact he's
even more committed to it so we're proud
to have JJ on our team we've got a lot
of young young men in our locker room
that we're very proud of guys like
Dwayne brown and andre johnson i could
go down the list got a lot of good
football players that are good citizens
of houston good to see you good to be an
extra spending time I appreciate it I'll
say hi next time would you please well
thanks for saying hello today Jamey
Rootes the team president the Houston
Texans
you